Welcome back.
I was just chugging through the
hairy math of this problem,
which I think we're
almost done.
But as I was saying, we're
just simplifying this.
We have 25 times sine
squared of 15 plus
cosine squared of 15.
I said well, that's
an identity, right?
Remember, I
undistributed this 25.
So sine squared plus cosine
squared of the same angle is 1.
So I can simplify this to --
and I will now change colors
just to be arbitrary.
So, 25 plus 100 minus 100
cosine of 15 degrees, and this
is what m squared is equal to,
and I used the variable m
because it stands for nothing
relevant to this problem.
And that equals 125 minus
100 cosine of 15 degrees.
Now I have to use a calculator
if I want to get a real answer.
But the possibility for error
is much lower now that I've
hopefully simplified it.
So I could use my calculator,
and the cosine of 15 degrees --
I'll write that down here, you
could just use a calculator or
table to figure that out --
it is equal to 0.96593.
So this term would be 125
minus 100 times this, right?
So what's 100 times this?
Well that's just minus 96.593,
right, I just did 100 times
the cosine of 15 degrees.
And now let me use the
trusty calculator to
figure out what that is.
So if I say 125 minus
96.593, I get 28.407.
So I have m squared
is equal to 28.407.
And so m is equal to the
square root of that.
It's going to be 5 point
something, right?
Square root.
5.3298.
So 5.33.
m is equal to 5.33.
And we're done.
The poor guy -- he's got to
figure out the right direction
to go in and he probably has to
think about the current in all
of that, but he hasn't asked us
that question so we
won't answer it.
But all he has left
to go is 5.33 miles.
So he only has to go an extra
0.33 miles than he would have,
had he gone in the right
direction from the get-go.
Hopefully that
makes some sense.
If it doesn't, well, not much
I can do, but maybe you
can re-watch this video.
Have fun.